HBO is doing everything in its power to
keep the secrets of game of thrones'
final season under wraps but that
doesn't stop the rumor mill from
whirling away nonetheless these are a
few of the spoilers that have slipped
out so far thanks to a first-look Set
report from Entertainment Weekly we now
know exactly how game of thrones' first
new episode will begin the season will
kick off in Winterfell as Daenerys
Targaryen drives her forces to the north
to help Jon Snow and his allies prepare
for battle against the Night king's army
the set up is expected to resemble the
pilot episodes big arrival of Robert
Baratheon and will usher in some
interesting reunions between various
characters at least one person will be
less than delighted at the new arrival
though with Sansa Stark reportedly being
displeased with John's decision to bend
the knee and allegiance to Daenerys
considering what they're all up against
however she might just have to get over
it executive producer Bryan cogman told
the magazine it's about all these
disparate characters coming together to
face a common enemy dealing with their
own past and defining the person they
want to be in the face of certain death
it's an incredibly emotional haunting
bittersweet final season and I think it
honors very much what George RR Martin's
set out to do in addition to Daenerys
his journey to Winterfell Jaime
Lannister is also expected to be heading
in that direction
although Nikolaj coster-waldau couldn't
guarantee he'll make it all the way
viewers of the 76th Golden Globe Awards
were treated to a brief but powerful new
teaser for game of thrones' upcoming
season although it was a blink and
you'll miss it reel the brief clip
contained a pretty big clue as to what
lies ahead for the show in the 8th
second piece of footage which launched
alongside a bevy of other HBO teaser
samples Sansa is shown coming
face-to-face with a mother of dragons at
long last
[Music]
when fellas yoga Oh grace it's hard to
tell whether Santa's gesture is
authentic or if she's becoming as
cunning as her late ear whisperer little
finger but in either case it's clear the
lady of Winterfell is going to cede some
power to Daenerys Targaryen for one
reason or another which is a pretty
surprising development given how
reluctant she was to let John flit off
the dragon stone and buddy up with
Daenerys in the first place in January
HBO released a new teaser for game of
thrones' season 8 that features Jon Snow
Sansa Stark and Arya Stark all convening
in the stark family crypt new to the
scene is a trio of statues that
represent the stark siblings themselves
and notably bran Stark is missing his
handicap has certainly never stopped him
from going places before so it can't
realistically be an access issue which
is keeping him at bay instead his
absence from the teaser may be a bit of
an official wink to the long-held fan
theory that bran Starks will become the
night team during one of his Ward's back
in time the idea is that since bran has
been able to affect certain aspects of
history in the past he may inadvertently
be the one to cause the ice zombies
ascent in the first place although she's
currently persona non grata with Jon
Snow and the rest of the North
Melisandre isn't done with her work for
the Lord of Light just yet I will return
to spider one last time
m'lady I have to die in this strange
country just like you some fans
theorized that the reason the red woman
is headed off to the free city of
Atlantis is to earn Redemption if she's
able to recruit the fiery hand the 1,000
soldiers who guard the city and follow
the teachings of the Lord of Light they
may prove to be invaluable to the final
battle where she to help Jon Snow and
Daenerys fight the night Kings army in
their hour of need she might even be
invited to remain without fear of
persecution for her past actions and
died in Westeros e'en soil as she
intends to get ready to spend more time
at the ancestral home of balerion the
dread because rumor has it that the
major players will all be meeting once
again in the dragon pits in season 8 and
for much longer this time
two Watchers on the wall reports that
filming at the Roman ruins of italica in
Seville were scheduled from April 23rd
to May 19 2008 een that's nearly four
weeks which is quadruple the time the
crew spent filming there for season
seven whether the scene is longer or
just more action-packed it's certain to
be substantially bigger and better than
the last time what's more there were no
additional casting calls for extras
which means it's probably safe to assume
that this particular scene will once
again feature only the main characters
we already know and if Sofie Turner's
talk of filming in Spain is a clue
then perhaps Sansa will get to save her
peace at the dragon pit two rumors from
the Dubrovnik Times indicate that the
last scene of the entire series may very
well take place at King's Landing
according to these reports the scene
would have been shot in January 2018
with tents in the old town of the
borough of Nick being a big sign that
something was shot at King's Landing
with most of the main cast no additional
extras were called beyond the main cast
members which is perhaps what caused
sources to speculate that it was in fact
the final scene nothing is official of
course but surely King's Landing
the infamous home of the Iron Throne
would be a fitting location to end the
series which is all about that seat of
power promising Lee the news that
multiple main cast members were present
is also a good indication that they
probably don't all die in the second war
for the dawn thank the gods for that
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you